soap bubbles captured at the moment they
burst explosions of color as painted
balloons go pop an art created by
centrifugal force frozen in time what's
fascinating about photography is that it
can freeze moments in time that are so
brief they can't be seen with the naked
eye with photography though you can
capture the moment and preserve it for
eternity that potential is what makes
photography so fascinating that
photography at his studio in a village
in northwestern Switzerland Ethne
experiments with his latest idea
he hopes to capture the moment a stone
hits a container full of paint he's come
up with a trick to trigger the shutter
at precisely the right millisecond
whenever a stone or an object touches
the surface of the pool it makes a sound
that's recorded by this device sends a
signal to the flashes which go off the
moment the stone hits Fabien ethno
spends weeks on the setup materials and
technology for each suit this series
will be called orchid I always try to
give people enough information to
understand what's behind the photo the
concept of it but not enough to go right
out and replicate it sometimes the
results of his work surprise even the
photographer himself many viewers are
amazed when they realize if nurse
pictures aren't painted Abu Dhabi for
instance here I took ferrofluid a
magnetic liquid and mixed it with water
colors suddenly I got these pop art like
structures with these black squiggles it
ended up looking a lot like Keith
Haring's pop art cluster throw a shark
on Keith Haring it in it enough nurse
work the laws of physics and other
natural phenomena take on a visible in
poetic form
his series dancing colors converts waves
of sound into vibrant works of art rock
rock music works best but I don't
usually use music I generally use sounds
like a brick and glass or heartbeat the
frequency of the sound then determines
what the structures look like sometimes
it's like a flower opening sometimes it
looks like an erupting volcano so the
result will vary a lot depending on the
audio frequency Fabienne
f nur isn't just an artist he's a
product designer
he's also lined up clients for a few of
his ideas in my opinion we don't play
right now I'm working on a few different
projects I'm I always work on several at
the same time when one of them stalls I
switched to a different one and rather
than my current project I'm mixing
gasoline with oil paints the second one
uses Scottish whiskey where I use
whiskey to produce structures that look
like a brain the third one is for the
perfume industry in that I mix various
drops of perfume to create little balls
of color and I'd advise that us the
couple of feet it's everyday science
transformed into eye catching art to see
Fabian earnest pictures is to find the
beauty in ordinary things
you